[Music]
hey what's up guys and welcome to
today's video in this one i'm going to
be talking about some of the elements
that go into improving your striking
speed
now if you're interested in this topic
head to my channel as well because in
the subsequent weeks to this
i'm going to be diving into each one of
these topics in a little bit more detail
in separate videos so
i'm going to be kind of just covering an
overview today and touching on each one
kind of like a
a bird's eye view and then i'll be
looking at them in much more depth on my
channel
and i've listed the points in this video
in a sort of order of rough importance
because
as i mentioned before you don't really
want to kind of like add a load of
special
advanced tactics onto poor foundational
elements because then
you're just going to be making kind of
like a bad technique even more strongly
kind of ingrained with into your muscle
memory
and once things become habits it's
really hard to break them a powerful
athlete isn't somebody that's simply
strong
but somebody that can exert that
strength with speed
and there's often a bit of a disconnect
between people when they think if
somebody's really fast that they can't
be powerful
because they think the two kind of like
you have to choose one or the other but
actually it's
completely the opposite of that and
they're connected so if you're able to
learn to move quicker you're going to
improve your power as a result because
then you're able to deliver that mass
forward
at such a rate that it's going to have a
greater impact when it reaches the
target
i think where that comes from is when
people look at this kind of stuff with
like an untrained eye
they kind of think that you know if
somebody's slim and not
packed with muscle that they must be uh
mustn't be powerful even if they're very
quick
but you know obviously like somebody
like me for instance who has a body type
like that i'm not gonna be as powerful
as somebody much heavier but it's about
power to weight ratio so for my size i'm
powerful
but i'm not gonna be as powerful as like
you know somebody much heavier than me
but of course that's that's not what
it's about it's about power to weight
ratio and not trying to just kind of
like gain a load of weight
thinking it's going to make you more
powerful because it doesn't really work
that way
the first point we're going to talk
about is relaxation and without
relaxation as a kind of
starting point then everything else
you're going to do after isn't going to
be as effective as it could be
so you need to be able to relax the
muscles completely before and after the
strike the only point of tension is
really as you hit
so even before you hit as well kind of
consciously relax your shoulders
then as you strike the only point of
which your body kind of becomes rigid
is as you hit the target or at the sort
of final point of the strike perhaps
like mentally an inch or so before the
target
then you relax again completely and draw
it back in and what this does is if the
muscles are tense when they're striking
then they're going to be fighting
against each other so you might think
you're moving more quickly but in
reality you're probably not
and also that sort of relaxation creates
like a towel whip effect where
it kind of lets the energy store up
until right at the end point whereas if
it's tense
it's going to be dissipated into the
muscles throughout the strike rather
than
exerting itself right at the end point
which is obviously what you want it to
do
so super important to stay relaxed
throughout and it also obviously
conserves your energy because if you
tense all the time it's kind of like
driving a car
at like um to its limit all the time
it's gonna run out of fuel more quickly
if you're trying to use all of your
energy
on every strike that you throw and use
like kind of uh muscle power and then
you're not gonna have the longevity of
performance and you're gonna really tire
quickly
so like i said the analogy of whipping a
towel is always really good for this you
you know like your wrist stays
completely relaxed as you do it
you whip that towel out and the only
point of which there's any tension is
the kind of cracking point right at the
end and then it's relaxed again
completely as it comes back so the
strike is going to leave your garden
position whether it's a kick or a punch
and the moment of tension is right
before
or as you hit the target that's when
your body becomes stiff and the energy
transfers
into that target then you relax again
and bring it down the same line ideally
as it comes back in
and the second point is technique and
our technique's not something generally
thought of when
talking about improving speed or speed
development but it is really one of the
most important areas because
you want to have your technique as
economical as possible and as efficient
as possible because if you're wasting
energy
and you're having to draw your the limbs
that you're striking with over a greater
distance then obviously that's going to
take up more time so
really developing that technique slowly
and shadow boxing is really good for
this slow shadow boxing to ensure
that you're moving along the correct
lines that you would like to before kind
of
adding that speed on so your body's not
having to do more than it needs to it's
kind of just going along the right lines
and then retracting it without wasting
that energy this also bleeds into
another point which is the order of
recruitment meaning
the order in which the muscles are
recruited when delivering and activating
a strike and throughout as well
if the muscles are not kind of working
together then the strike might come out
from the wrong position or you know you
might be sort of like turning your body
too early things like movement of the
shoulders you know
the use of the body to get the weight
behind the strikes and so on really
refining that technique making sure the
muscles are all kind of working together
is going to improve massively towards
your speed and it's something that you
should do
before kind of trying to build on any
strength or any other
drills to kind of improve the speed that
way
[Music]
now the third point in this is intention
and what i mean by intention is pretty
much kind of like
it's not exactly this but the best way i
can describe it with words is like the
kind of determination to hit although
it's not exactly that there's a little
bit more to it than that
so rather than just kind of going
through the motions like a lot of people
do when they train
it's actually kind of having the
intention behind each strike and wanting
to move quickly
it's partly like a kind of mindset thing
a little bit like the relaxation that
you have to be conscious of when you
train
but it is also physical as well the
reason it's so difficult to describe
is because the definition of intention
meaning having say a determination to
act
is only really a prelude to the power
that implements the action it's not
actually what does the action itself
that's something that's almost
intangible it's like you can't really
explain how you just
do it and that's what i mean by
intention is having that kind of mind
muscle connection that you want to move
in that way and
it's super important and super powerful
even though it kind of seems
almost like just a kind of afterthought
it's one of the most important things
that you should focus upon when going
into training
number four is shadow boxing and shadow
boxing is obviously
something that has been utilized by
boxes and martial artists for
generations
it can be used for many different things
but in terms of developing speed it's a
super useful tool because you're able to
hit without restriction or hindrance
and you're able to complete the full
strike and draw it back in again as fast
as you want
the way i would use shadow boxing to
develop speed is a little bit different
to just kind of using it as a warm-up
for instance where you're focusing upon
all elements like
footwork and head movement and things so
if you want to concentrate on just speed
then i'd recommend doing just some very
simple combinations kind of like
building up in speed as you go
but eventually to where you're doing
them as fast as you can while completing
the full strikes
so it's common when people are trying to
move quickly for them to sort of
subconsciously cut the strike short but
that's not going to do you any favors
and you're just going to be kind of
cheating yourself and not doing the full
technique
and just completing those combinations
as fast as you can really focusing upon
good technique and being nice and quick
and explosive while remaining relaxed
[Music]
there's a little bit of a disagreement
with people about whether shadow boxing
with weights
improves speed or is more of a kind of
conditioning exercise
and i tend to lean on the kind of
condition inside because really like if
you went running with a huge backpack
full of weight on it and then took it
off it's going to feel like you would be
able to run quicker afterwards but
really it's just that you've taken the
backpack off
and that's kind of the same with the
shadow boxing with weights the way
you're actually using those weights you
only use very light weights
and the direction at which you're
punching the weights aren't actually
providing any resistance against the
punches they're more kind of like
pulling down obviously
even the pros when you see them do this
they do very slow movements and they do
kind of like very circular movements so
it's more for kind of working the
shoulders in my opinion rather than kind
of trying to improve
speed
[Music]
the last one is sport specific
conditioning drills and the reason this
is at the end
is because this is something to do once
you've kind of got all of the other
elements going on as well
because if you do start to do loads of
um conditioning drills and stuff
while your technique's really bad then
you're not going to do yourself any
favors
and we want to obviously be working in a
way that's going to develop the right
muscle fibers for explosive hand and leg
speed
in this case it's the type 2 or fast
twitch fibers i'm not going to go into
this too much in detail because adam's
more than covered that in many many
other videos so
if you want to do that i'm sure you'll
be able to find something else on this
channel that covers that and i'm going
to cover this in much greater detail on
my own channel once that episode is
uploaded but i'm just going to show you
now a few different things what i like
to do and i feel have really helped
contribute to my speed and explosiveness
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm a big believer in kind of volume
training and consistency over
sporadic bursts of intensity so i would
recommend doing these at kind of mid to
to sort of like just above mid level
intensity so
if these are kind of taken away from
your actual skill focus
then you've kind of gone a little bit
too far in my opinion so it's like if
they're really aching you and you're not
able to say
go and do your striking better the next
day or whatever then you're going to be
too far
i think the best way to do this kind of
stuff is on the same day as you do that
or in us in a separate session but don't
do too much it should only really be
about 15
of your total workload so that the main
thing is your skill focus because the
best way to develop is just to do the
skill and this stuff should just be kind
of as extra
the only thing that i would really
recommend focusing upon separately
is some kind of focused core work
because the core is the vital link
between the lower and upper body and
obviously plays a huge part in
transferring the energy from the ground
into your strikes so definitely focus
upon some core work and these are some
ones that i like to do personally
[Music]
so those were some elements that are
going to help to improve your striking
speed overall
and you want to basically kind of just
get used to moving the body more and
getting quicker at moving the body
in general because it's about the whole
body it's like a holistic approach and
if you're much more agile overall then
your strikes are naturally going to be
quicker
that can be achieved as well through
kind of full body agility work like you
know jump rope and use of the things
like the agility ladder and things like
that which are tools i really like to
use
and there isn't really any magic trick
to this other than just training
if you were going to look for one
element that was really going to kind of
pull all this together
it's having fun while you're doing it
because then it's going to become
addictive and you're going to want to do
it more naturally without having to
force yourself to do it
and obviously that's going to add up to
a lot more hours and you're going to
become more consistent
and much more refined in your technique
and your skills so that's going to be it
for this video guys remember as i said
before to head to my channel because i'm
going to be looking at each of these
elements
in much more depth over the coming weeks
and you can obviously interact with me
there much more ask any questions about
them and things like that so thanks very
much guys and i'll see you next time